guys in case you've missed it yesterday
we've had a lot of fun here in this
video
graphic artists look like they're having
some fun too let's talk about what
happened yesterday check this out boom
okay what are you doing there why are
you taking my king oh my God the king
the crown fell off your king is broken
what's wrong
there you have it there you have it why
is the square should we glue it should
we should we should we put it just
[Laughter]
is like what's forever like fire water
it's okay it's okay look you're King
look if we put the if we put the peg
back here look the bag is falling out
man oh no he lifted up my king he can't
lift up my king but it's broken how's he
smiling guys he's like
[Laughter]
Frank
what's for dinner guys what's for dinner
Frankie's trying to I think he said calm
down guys
and then Fabby responded to all of this
the disrespected just reached its peak
decapitated
yeah oh that was just so fun that was
what provoked you to this discover and
there's the parking lot discussion Yes
actually they spent 15 minutes talking
about the game and it looked friendly
even though everybody was ready for any
kind of right they spent a lot of time
so discussing yeah so we were actually
witnessed another King's Gambit version
yesterday yeah but it was Kingsgate
right
Kingsgate Blue Gate however